Speaker 1: Welcome to the program. Those of you
who are watching will see I'm wearing my John
Fetterman hoodie today. John Fetterman did indeed
win his Senate race yesterday. That is really good
news. And I want to start with the results from
these extraordinarily important 2022 midterms.
I will not rehash all of the reasons why these
midterms are so important, not the least of which,
however, it should be said, is trying to maintain
a democracy in which not just this year, but in
two years. In 2024, we can be confident that the
candidates who get the most votes are accepted
as the winners and assume their offices without
controversy. And we know that that almost didn't
happen in 2020. Expectations increasingly were
for an overwhelming red wave that would devastate
Democrats. It didn't happen. It didn't happen. We
still don't know. It's still unclear. Big picture,
who's going to end up controlling the House.
Republicans have picked up seats, but as of right
now, we don't know who will control the House. We
don't know for sure who will control the Senate.
But things are looking increasingly okay there
for Democrats and some critical gubernatorial
races. MAGA candidates failing miserably, and
this result is a disaster for Republicans. Now,
I know that there are people tweeting me saying,
David, Republicans will probably still take the
House and then the Senate is going to be split
at it. What do you mean? It's a disaster for
Republicans. Historically, Republicans should have
done really well. And based on all of the polling
that Republicans themselves were pointing to, they
were saying this is going to be overwhelming, it's
going to be open and shut. Republicans easily take
the House with a nice margin. Republicans take
the Senate, Republicans win all of the critical
gubernatorial races. None of that is happening.
None of that is happening. Oz and Mastriano
lost, Tudor Dixon lost. Herschel Walker currently
losing, but probably heading towards a runoff. And
we will see where that goes. Lauren Boebert might
lose boebert an incumbent maga republican. Blake
Masters down. It will probably be called today
for his opponent, mark kelly. Sarah Palin laughed
away. Kari Lake. We don't yet know, but she very
well may lose, even though it increasingly was
being said, Oh, Carrie, legs are going to win
and if Republicans take the House, it will be
by the smallest margin. Let's get right into it,
starting with the Senate. Who will control the
Senate? Right now we know 48, 48 Republicans
have so far not made any pickups and Democrats
have as of right now made one pickup. If we look
at flipped seats, that is indeed Pennsylvania,
where John Fetterman has defeated television.
Dr. Mehmet Oz, with 94% of the vote in
it is Fetterman, a little over 50 odds,
a little over 47, about three points separating
them. That is a really good result. Fetterman is
a really good candidate who suffered a stroke
some months ago, struggled in a recent debate.
Clearly not a cognitive issue. If you've seen
in particular his speeches recently, if you see
him right, this is an auditory processing issue
and it seems that the voters realize that. Now,
what's the counterpoint? A quack TV doctor
who has no business being senator. Almost one
right that you can always find pros and cons
there. If we go back to the broader Senate map,
a critical race is that in Georgia, Raphael
Warnock, the incumbent Democrat, trying to beat
off a challenge from serial liar and completely
clueless, barely able to speak. Former football
player Herschel Walker. There is what's called
the 50% rule in Georgia. If neither candidate
gets 50%, there would be a runoff. There are three
candidates and the third party candidate, Oliver,
has just over 2% of the vote right now. Raphael
Warnock is leading by half a point, which is
18,000 votes. No matter where this shakes out, if
it's Warnock by half a point or Walker by half a
point, it doesn't look as though either will get
to that 50% mark, meaning there will be a runoff
if that's the case. We're all going to Georgia.
And I don't know if I will physically be going
to Georgia. I may or we may try to figure
out digitally how to pour everything we can.
Herschel Walker must not be allowed to become a
senator in the United States. It's horrifying.
Other important races in North Carolina,
it briefly looked like Beasley might have
a chance. The Democrat at Defense at taking that
seat from Ted Budd. Ultimately, it did go for Ted,
but it was expected. But there was a brief glimmer
of hope there. In Ohio, J.D. Vance did defeat Tim
Ryan. That was expected. The polling was really
pretty clear there. An extremely important race
is Arizona. It has not yet been called. It is
starting to look like it will be. I want to be
careful because news continues to break. Blake
Masters may be the worst person in the world.
As an individual, Walker is less qualified,
but Blake Masters seems like a genuinely
worse person. Mark Kelly, the incumbent right now
leading by five. There is speculation it might be
called today. Only 69% of the vote is in there. A
couple of other key races in the state of Nevada.
Adam Laxalt has taken the lead against Cortez
Masto. That's disappointing. And we are going
to keep an eye on that. And in Wisconsin, we still
don't know for sure, but with 94% of the vote in,
Ron Johnson, the incumbent, is looking
like he's going to be able to stave off
a challenge from Mandela. Barnes, a great guy
who has been a guest on this program. 6% of the
vote remains to be counted and we can maintain
some amount of hope there. So in the Senate
right now, completely plausible that Democrats
maintain control. We will know probably within a
couple of days. Looking now at gubernatorial races
again. Not a disaster for Democrats with what we
know so far. Democrats have made two pickups in
terms of governors and Republicans have made none.
Important races there, of course, Pennsylvania,
where thankfully Josh SHAPIRO, a great candidate,
a genuinely great candidate, has easily
defeated conspiracy theorist MAGA. Trump Riot
Steal the election lunatic Doug Mastriano. This
could decide the 2024 presidential election. The
winner of this race, which is Josh SHAPIRO,
will decide who is the secretary of state in
Pennsylvania. And that person will run the 2024
election, which could decide who is president
of the United States of critical importance.
We're also looking very strongly at Arizona.
Kerry Lake. A complete cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs.
Conspiracy theorists who wanted to secede. Who
wants to end all abortion? A dangerous, dangerous
woman. Right now, she's down 6/10 of a point.
We have to wait. We are hopeful. We are hopeful.
Kerry Lake will lose in Georgia. As expected,
Brian Kemp did defeat Stacey Abrams. That's too
bad. But it was expected based on the polling. In
Texas, Beto O'Rourke lost badly to incumbent Greg
Abbott. Better. O'Rourke's political future is
definitely in question after yet another worse
than expected loss in Michigan. Fortunately,
this is another loss for MAGA. Tudor Dixon,
the Trump endorsed conspiracy theorist,
lost by ten to the incumbent Democratic governor
Gretchen Whitmer, while Wisconsin, rather,
was briefly in question. But Evers defeated
Michaels by about three and a half points.
That's really great news. And we're still waiting
for results from Oregon, which if the Republican
Drazan or Drazen, I forget the pronunciation
were to win in Oregon, it would be the first
Republican governor in decades. Right now, Kotek,
the Democrat is ahead by one. Only 76% of the vote
has been counted. And lastly, we have the House
of Representatives. The House of Representatives,
the most likely to go to Republicans. Indeed,
Republicans have currently made it ten pickups.
They need 17 more seats to take control. It was
apparently a foregone conclusion. It is now not
a foregone conclusion. If they win, it will be
a small margin. One interesting race hard to
focus on a lot of races here, but if we do go
to Colorado and you go to the third district,
the third district, you will see that Lauren
Boebert is losing by one point to Lauren Boebert,
if she is defeated, would be the second big
MAGA cartoon to lose this cycle. Madison
Cawthorn losing his primary after not even a full
term. It's possible Lauren Boebert will lose as
well. 90% of the vote is in. She's the incumbent.
She's a MAGA extremist, and she is currently down
by 1.2. This all may come down in terms of the
Senate to Georgia. There is no red wave. The red
wave is dead. Do not let anybody trick you. And
I will even have clips of Republicans admitting
this momentarily. But the red wave is dead. There
may be a ripple. Should have been a great midterm
for Republicans. It'll end up being sort of okay
and of critical importance. Democratic governors
won in Pennsylvania, Michigan and Wisconsin.
Those three races this year could determine
who the next president of the United States is.
And we'll have time to talk about that as well.